[APPLAUSE]
SCOTT MAXWELL: So Emily,
this is your first book.
EMILY LAKDAWALLA: It is.
SCOTT MAXWELL: You
didn't want to start
with something simpler?
A brief history of time, maybe?
I mean, I know that's been done.
But, as you write
in the book, this
is the most complicated
robot ever sent
to another planet-- in
fact, ever sent off Earth.
Why did you want to
write about this,
and why do you say that
it's the most complicated?
EMILY LAKDAWALLA:
Well, I think it's
fair to admit that
I didn't realize
what I was getting into when
I started writing this book.
In fact, as I explain
in the introduction,
it's not actually the book that
I meant to write to begin with.
I was approached by
Springer to write a book
about the Curiosity mission.
And I wrote, and I
wrote, and I wrote.
And I wasn't finishing,
and I wound up
with a tremendous
quantity of material
and wasn't able to wrap it up.
And I finally figured
out that the reason
I was having so much trouble
was because I had accidentally
written two books.
And so this is
actually just the first
of a pair of books on Curiosity.
The second one is going
to be coming out next year
and will be about
the science mission.
So I kind of was able to
partition the engineering
stuff into one book and the
science to another book.
And basically, this is the
book that I needed in order
to be able to understand
the Rover well enough
to be able to write about
its science mission.
And so now I'm writing
about the science.
I've got a copy on
my desk and I keep
on referring to it all the time.
How many of this
thing does it have?
And how long did it,
and when did this fail?
And it's all in there.
SCOTT MAXWELL: So
tell us a little more
about why it is the
most-- what makes it
the most complicated robot
we've ever sent off this planet?
EMILY LAKDAWALLA: It's
sort of the culmination
of a long history of
NASA's exploration of Mars.
And I think that the
key to its complexity
is that NASA builds from
one mission to the next.
You begin with a very basic,
broad set of questions.
What is Mars?
And you map it, and you
find out some more things
about what it is.
And then you ask more
detailed questions.
Was water ever
important on Mars?
And Spirit and Opportunity
were sent with this mantra,
"follow the water."
Try to understand how water
was active on Mars in the past.
Curiosity's questions are
more subtle than that.
We know that there
was water on Mars,
but did they ever have
a habitable environment
that microorganisms might
have been able to live in?
And so as the
questions get subtler,
the investigations
that you have to do
to try to answer those
questions get more detailed,
more complicated.
It's not enough just to
snap pictures anymore.
You have to have much more
detailed kinds of data.
Curiosity has these two highly
sophisticated laboratory
instruments that are designed
to ingest solid samples
and perform x-ray diffraction
and x-ray fluorescence.
It performs gas chromatograph
mass spectrometry
with a tunable
laser spectrometer
and a quadruple
mass spectrometer.
It's got all of these
laboratory instruments
that have been miniaturized
to fit inside the Rover.
And so just supporting
that hardware
requires a host
of subsystems that
are necessary to
keep the thing alive.
You also have to have a mission
that lasts a lot longer.
The warranty on
Spirit and Opportunity
is famously only 90 days.
And of course,
Opportunity is still
going after 5,000
and something sols.
Do you know off the top
of your head how many?
SCOTT MAXWELL: Let me
check my Mars time app.
Why, it's 5,107
sols today, Emily.
EMILY LAKDAWALLA:
All right, very good.
So yeah, Curiosity has not
lasted nearly so long yet.
And in fact, it's quite
likely that Curiosity will not
last as many sols
as Opportunity does.
It's almost certain.
But anyway, the point is
that Opportunity was only
warranted to last 90 days.
It was supposed to be able to
accomplish its prime mission
in that amount of time.
Curiosity's warranty ran
out after a first year.
And so you have to
build much more robust--
SCOTT MAXWELL:
First Martian year.
EMILY LAKDAWALLA: --systems.
First Martian-- yeah,
first Martian year, yes.
That's correct.
You have to build much
more robust systems
to be able to
support all of that.
And so that also made it
more complex because you
have a lot of redundancy
and other things built in
to make it just last so long.
SCOTT MAXWELL: And famously, one
of those two labs that you were
talking about, the
Sample Analysis at Mars,
or SAM instrument, I think
was Rick Welch who pointed out
that that instrument alone is
larger than the entire chassis
of the Mars exploration Rovers.
EMILY LAKDAWALLA:
That's right, yeah.
And it's big.
It's heavier than the
Sojourner Rover was.
I mean, it's the
size of a microwave,
which, in Earth terms, for
a laboratory instrument,
it's amazingly miniature.
But in terms of what
a mobile Rover has
to support on the surface of
another planet, it's enormous.
It has high power demands.
It has exacting
temperature requirements.
And it's just a very
complicated piece of machinery.
SCOTT MAXWELL: I
think that might
be the size of the entire first
Rover that we sent, Sojourner.
It's like SAM is the
size of Sojourner,
bigger than the chassis of
the Mars exploration Rovers.
So you did an enormous
amount of research.
It shows, and it pays off
really well in this book.
This, by the way, is
the first technically--
I've read a lot of
technically-oriented books
in my life, and this is the
first technically-oriented book
that I've read that uses
terms like "stubborn gunk."
I think it does a very
good job of making
these very complicated things
accessible to a lay audience.
And that's kind of an outgrowth
of the work that you do.
You are the Senior Editor
and Planetary Evangelist
at the Planetary Society.
Do you see this as kind of
an outgrowth of that work?
EMILY LAKDAWALLA:
Oh, absolutely.
So I see what I do at
the Planetary Society
as kind of a
translation function.
There are so many
exciting things
happening in science and
engineering and space
exploration right now.
And while I was a grad student
exploring these things,
I thought, this
stuff is really cool,
but nobody learns about it.
And one of the main reasons
that nobody learns about it
is that the ways that scientists
and engineers communicate
with each other are really,
frankly, kind of horrible.
Science papers are just bad.
They're boringly written.
They're difficult to understand.
But when you train as a
scientist or engineer,
you learn that
language and you become
capable of reading it
and understanding it.
And you learn to use
a whole new vocabulary
of terms that have very
specific and precise meanings.
But when you use that
same language to speak
to a member of the
public, you are basically
speaking a language that's
foreign to that member
of the public.
So you have to translate.
And one of the
phrases that I hate
the most in public
communication is "dumbing down,"
because you're not
making things stupider.
You are translating
to a language
that you can use to
communicate with other people.
And so it's perfectly
possible to get
across complicated concepts.
You just have to use the words
that people can understand.
So when I need to write
about stubborn gunk,
I write about stubborn gunk
because that's exactly what
we're talking about.
We're talking
about material that
is sticking to the
sides of an instrument
that you can't get off
even by shaking it.
And that's what
the Phoenix Lander
was dealing with in the section
that I wrote that about.
And you know, you've all
dealt with that problem
in your own homes and
lives, I'm quite sure.
And it's just it's better to
write about it in that way.
It's more exciting.
It is just as effective
at communication
as saying, I don't know,
high viscosity material that
has adsorbed onto the walls
of the sample collection
device or something like that.
You could say it that way.
But why?
SCOTT MAXWELL: I wonder if,
instead of dumbing down,
we could say that this is a
smarting down of the Rover?
EMILY LAKDAWALLA:
Just a translation.
It's a translation
of how everything
works to make it more
accessible to people
who are non-native
speakers of science.
SCOTT MAXWELL: And you're
well-positioned to do that,
having trained as a
scientist yourself.
That's also your background.
EMILY LAKDAWALLA: Yeah.
So I'm a planetary
geologist by training.
So as an undergrad,
I did field geology.
I got to walk
around on mountains
and whack things
with rock hammers
and draw pencil and color
pencil maps and things.
And then, in grad school,
I studied geology on Venus
using radar images
from the Magellan
Orbiter, which is
just-- it's such
an underappreciated mission.
It ended in the early '90s.
It mapped all of Venus
in radar wavelengths.
And Venus is a
fascinating-looking planet,
and I really wish NASA would get
a mission back there sometime
soon.
But it's hard to
study because of
the insanely high temperatures
and the sulfuric acid clouds.
And the pressure at
the surface is the same
as at a mile beneath
the ocean, so it's
tough to build hardware
that survives for very long
on Venus.
SCOTT MAXWELL: Yeah.
I wouldn't want
to be the guy who
has to design the Rover that can
rove around where temperatures
will melt lead.
EMILY LAKDAWALLA: Yes.
SCOTT MAXWELL: That
doesn't seem like fun.
EMILY LAKDAWALLA: Yeah.
Solder is not going to work.
And the Russians succeeded in
exploring the surface of Venus
by essentially building--
I mean, it's an exaggeration,
but they were basically
clockwork spacecraft.
I mean, they were
mechanical spacecraft
because you can build
mechanical components that can
work at very high temperatures.
Electronics, especially
in the 1970s,
were not ready to operate at
those kinds of conditions.
And the Russians,
being the Russians,
built these big,
robust spacecraft
that basically worked with
these mechanical systems
and were able to
take measurements
after landing on the surface for
a matter of minutes to an hour
or so before the
spacecraft failed.
And that's how we know anything
about the surface of Venus.
SCOTT MAXWELL: So
returning our attention
to Mars, one of the things
I think you do really
well in this book--
which I greatly enjoyed reading
and enthusiastically recommend,
by the way--
one of things I think you
really do well in this book
is you don't just translate
all of the technical jargon
in terms that people
can understand.
But you also recognize--
and this is, again,
part of your work at the
Planetary Society, I think--
that you can't talk about
this Rover just as a machine.
It's not just that the
Rover is a machine.
It's that the Rover
carries with it
a lot of human
hopes and ambitions.
And I think you kind of
communicate that, as well,
what we're were hoping
and dreaming to explore
on the surface of Mars.
EMILY LAKDAWALLA: Yeah.
There's a book that
was written, actually,
by a sociologist named Janet
Vertesi, who has embedded
with several of NASA's
JPLs operations teams
on space missions.
And she studies the sociology
of how teams work when
they work on these missions.
And one of the most
striking things
that she observed that really
made me sit back and go, huh,
is the pronoun that JPL
engineers and scientists use
when they refer to the Rover.
Sometimes some
people do say "it."
It can be traditional to call
ships of exploration "she,"
like ocean-going ships are
often referred to as "she."
But it's not actually
very common to use
that pronoun for Curiosity.
The most common pronoun is "we."
And so think about
that for a minute, what
it means to be referring
to this machine as "we."
It means that we are exploring
Mars, we drilled today,
we are driving across that hill.
It's not just one machine.
It's the embodiment of all
of the people participating
together on this mission.
And it's such a team
thing, especially
because of the way that there
are all these operational roles
on the mission, and
many different people
who can fill those operational
roles on any given day.
So it feels more like--
I don't know, it feels kind
of like being on a ship
on the ocean, in a way,
where there is a captain,
but there's all these other
commanders and everything else.
And every person has their part
to contribute to make it going.
And together, you're on this
great ship of exploration.
And that's what
Curiosity feels like.
And so it kind of
feels like there
is a false dichotomy between
human and robotic exploration
because this is
human exploration.
We are seeing the
surface of Mars.
We're exploring places
that humans could never go,
at least not now.
And we're doing it through
the eyes of robots.
And I think that, as virtual
reality gets more commonplace,
as we decrease the
separation between humans
and the machines and the
software that we use,
we're actually going
to see a merging
of human and robotic
exploration, where we may have
human exploration of
the surface of Venus,
except that it'll be humans in
an orbiting spacecraft using
robotic avatars to
explore the surface.
And it sounds science
fiction-y, but it's really not
that far-fetched, given
current technology,
and would be a much
more efficient way
for us to get human brains into
environments that are really
hard for humans to survive.
Terrible radiation
environments, terrible heat,
crushing pressure,
all of those things.
We just put robot
bodies down there.
And if we can manage to use our
human brains effectively, then
that's, I think, the
future of exploration.
SCOTT MAXWELL: Right.
And then you haven't gone
down into the gravity well
and say, no, I have to get
the people boosted back
off the planet.
EMILY LAKDAWALLA:
Also that, yeah.
SCOTT MAXWELL: So you
can land the humans
on Phobos or something and have
them tele-operating a mission
on the surface below them.
EMILY LAKDAWALLA: It
turns out to be harder
to do aerial synchronous
orbits-- that's
Mars geosynchronous
orbits-- than it
is to do Earth geosynchronous
orbits because Mars's gravity
field is a lot lumpier.
And so it's hard to do station
keeping with your spacecraft,
to keep it positioned over
a single spot on Mars.
But there are two stable
positions in longitude,
or meta stable positions.
So you have to really want to
explore the part of Mars that's
underneath those two
stable positions.
SCOTT MAXWELL: So you
were talking about the way
that we embody the Rover,
that we are the Rover,
and the language that's used.
But another thing that
Janet Vertesi pointed out
was that, in the same way
as we by embody the Rover,
we also use our bodies to
communicate about the Rover.
And so, for example, with
Spirit and Opportunity,
we'll talk about the
solar panels by--
you bend your body forward,
you splay your arms backward
in this position
because that's what
the solar panels look like.
When you talk about the
solar panels, you do that.
When you talk about
the mobility system,
you kind of move your arms
in this characteristic way,
and steer the wheels like this.
And when you talk about the
robotic arm, you use your arm,
and it's always the left arm
because they're left-armed.
Did you find yourself
doing that when
you were writing this book?
Did you kind of inhabit
the Rover's body that way?
EMILY LAKDAWALLA: I
did that a little bit.
But I actually find myself doing
it a lot less with Curiosity
than I do with Spirit
and Opportunity.
SCOTT MAXWELL: Everybody
else does, too.
EMILY LAKDAWALLA: Yeah.
Spirit and Opportunity
have this--
they're much more human scale
and they're symmetrical.
It's much more easy
to imagine them
as having the body plan of a
person or a donkey or a dog
or whatever you
want to imagine it.
Curiosity is not
nearly as symmetrical.
It's not nearly as pretty.
And to be honest, I really
didn't like the appearance
of Curiosity when I
first started doing
the research on this book.
I often feel like--
you know, there's
these three
generations of Rovers.
There's Sojourner, Spirit and
Opportunity, and Curiosity.
And I feel like Sojourner was
sort of a loyal little dog.
It couldn't ever go any farther
out of sight of the lander
because it didn't have its
own communication skills.
So it just kind of
poked around rocks.
You could even see these images
of it lifting its leg on a rock
because it drives up,
and it kept driving.
And there's actually an image
of the Rover perched almost
sideways on a rock like this.
And then Spirit and Opportunity
are much more surefooted.
They're bigger.
They're more human scale.
So in my extended
animal metaphor,
they're the burrows,
or the donkeys
that used to accompany the
western geologists as they
explored the geology
in the American West.
And then, what does
that make Curiosity?
It's the animal
designed by committee.
It's a camel.
It's a ship of the desert.
It moves slowly and steadily
across the desert landscape,
carrying its lumbering
load with it.
And that's what
Curiosity is like.
And like I said, I
didn't really love it
when I first saw the design.
But that changed, actually.
The JPL had an
opportunity for the media
to come into the clean room
and see Curiosity before it got
shipped to Florida for launch.
And so I was actually
able to put on--
they call it a bunny suit,
the white suit and the cap
and everything else--
and go in and see
Curiosity face to face.
And I have to say that I kind
of fell in love with Curiosity
when I had the opportunity
to sit there and meet
it face to face.
But yeah, I don't feel like
I embody Curiosity nearly as
much because it's so ungainly.
It's a different
kind of creature
from Spirit and Opportunity.
SCOTT MAXWELL: And that
seems to be kind of
widespread on the project, too.
Ashwin Vasavada talks about
that, about how people have--
he feels like people
have emotionally
connected with Curiosity
less than with Spirit
and Opportunity.
EMILY LAKDAWALLA: I
think, also, it may partly
be because of the way that
Spirit and Opportunity are
much more responsive, in a way.
You come in on a morning,
you plan the day,
and then that's it.
Whereas Curiosity has to be
planned by committees, as well,
where you have as many
as four parallel planning
processes that are happening
at the same time operating
on different time scales.
You do have a
tactical operations
team that is planning
every day of operations.
But then there is a
look-ahead planning team
that is planning a couple
of days of operations.
There is a long-term planning
team that's looking out months.
And then there's a
project science group
that is kind of keeping
track of all of the mission
requirements.
And unlike Spirit
and Opportunity,
most of the decisions
for Curiosity
get made many more
days in advance.
So it's much less responsive.
So it feels, in
a way, a lot more
like some of the other
big NASA missions,
like Cassini, or these
other things that
need to be planned
much longer in advance.
SCOTT MAXWELL: It's kind of
this weird hybrid for that,
and also for project
management reasons
because it has lots of PIs
for the different instruments,
instead of one PI overseeing
them all, as on Spirit
and Opportunity.
And so there's this kind
of council of monarchs who
are kind of in charge of it.
EMILY LAKDAWALLA: I call
it the council of elders.
They're all the men, by
the way, which I hate.
It's really bad.
So there's this group of 12
PIs, and they're all men.
There's a lot of awesome
women working on this team.
SCOTT MAXWELL: A lot of great
engineers working on the team
and working on
operations, as well.
And in fact, one of the things
I was going to ask you about
was--
you cite some of those
women in the book,
the women who designed
the SA/SPaH, for example,
the sample acquisition
and handling system.
Are you hoping that--
as you are well-known for
your science outreach,
you're also well-known as
being an advocate of women
in science and engineering.
And are you hoping that one of
the many effects of this book
will be to encourage women to
go into science and engineering,
to see that there's a role
for them in this kind of work?
EMILY LAKDAWALLA: I don't
think that that's something
that I see coming as an
outcome of this book.
I think the book is designed
to feed people's insatiable
curiosity about
what Curiosity is.
And honestly, as a
parent of two daughters,
I don't see any
problems with the number
of women who want to go into
science and engineering.
SCOTT MAXWELL: Yeah, sure.
EMILY LAKDAWALLA: It's whether
science and engineering wants
to keep them there,
really, ultimately.
These missions are really
hard because they operate--
when you first land on Mars,
the amount of time you spend,
just continuous hours
working on these missions,
it's kind of nightmarish.
And I don't really go into
that that much in this book.
If you're interested
in books where
the life of being on
a mission is central,
there's another
recently published book
by Alan Stern and David
Grinspoon called "Chasing New
Horizons".
It's about the New
Horizons mission to Pluto.
And at every stage
of that mission,
it was like, we thought
we were all in before,
but we had to get
even more all in.
And then I started
working 16 hours a day
and getting by on
three hours of sleep.
And it's like the four
yorkshiremen sketch
from "Monty Python."
It just keeps on
getting worse and worse.
And you wonder how people
can last like this.
And people with families can't
last like that for very long.
So you have primarily
young people
working on missions, at
least on tactical operations.
It's difficult.
Now, over time, on
a mission like this,
they were able to change
the operational structure.
So first, after 90 days,
they went off of Mars time.
So Mars time is where
you set your clock
to the rotational
rate of Mars, which
has days 40 minutes
longer than Earth days.
And Scott, you're always
my example of the weirdo
who loves Mars time because
if you are a person who's
a night owl with no children--
you have children now,
of course-- but if you are
a night owl with no children
and you love to
sleep in, what's not
to love about sleeping in
40 minutes later every day?
It sounds great.
But if you have any connection
with the rest of humanity--
SCOTT MAXWELL: Which
I totally don't.
EMILY LAKDAWALLA: It's
absolutely miserable.
If you have children or
a spouse or partner who
wants to see you during
ordinary daylight hours,
it's absolutely miserable.
It's also kind of dangerous.
I was on Mars time with
Spirit and Opportunity
for a little while.
And because the schedule
slips around the clock,
you wind up sleep-deprived
driving home
after being up all night
during morning rush hour,
or on empty highways,
and you fall asleep
while driving and
get into a wreck.
And Steve Squires was actually
really concerned about this
and did all kinds of training
for the operations team
before the mission started.
But anyway, after 90 days,
they knew this mission
was a marathon, not a sprint.
They quickly went
off of Mars time.
After 180 days, they
stopped working on Sundays.
After another 90 days, they
stopped working on Saturdays.
And what that means is that it
really builds up your Friday.
You have to produce a three-sol
plan, a three-day plan,
on a Friday.
And sometimes it
means that you're not
taking advantage of the full
capability of the Rover.
But they do clever things,
like some of these instruments,
like the SAM instrument,
has to cook samples
in an oven that is
tremendously power-demanding.
So you might, say, cook them
in an oven on a Saturday
and just take Sunday
off to let the batteries
recharge because the Rover
would have to do that anyway.
So you might as
well do it at a time
when you don't want to
double up on your planning.
And so over time,
they have actually
managed to get the
operations requirement down
to about nine hours a day.
It's still a little
bit long work day.
They still do play with
the calendar a bit,
so sometimes you have to come
in and work at 6:00, 7:00 AM
because that's when you
need to get the commands up
to the Rover before 2:00
PM or whatever it is.
Sometimes you have
to come in late.
But now they allow everybody
to have a good night's sleep,
except for the
poor ChemCam team.
ChemCam is one of
the instruments,
and it's operated from France.
So now that they're
on Earth time,
the poor ChemCam team
primarily works overnight,
and it's kind of
misery for them.
But they trade off.
They work into operational
roles over time.
They might have two
days on ops per week,
and then the rest of the
week they're not on ops
and they don't have
to do that schedule.
And so I find that, as
these missions go on,
you find a lot of older--
a lot more women--
people coming into operations
because the work time
is much more predictable,
and it's much easier
to balance it with all
the other obligations you
may have in your daily life.
SCOTT MAXWELL: So to your point
about families on Mars time,
you'll remember that
when Curiosity landed,
there was an engineer,
David Oh, who--
he and his wife and
their two kids all
went on Mars time
together because the kids
didn't have to be back in
school for a month or a month
and a half or
something like that.
And so they all just
went on Mars time.
The whole family was
living on Mars time,
which was the first of
those that I've heard of.
EMILY LAKDAWALLA:
Yeah, they had a blog.
SCOTT MAXWELL: But your point
is well-taken about that
doesn't work for
everybody all the time.
EMILY LAKDAWALLA: It
was actually great.
They talked about
what can you do
in Los Angeles with
two young children
at midnight, at 2:00 AM?
And they found all
kinds of interesting
walks they could do with
lights and things like that.
It was actually a
pretty cool blog.
Going to the beach overnight
is really interesting.
And so they had a good time.
They saw lots of
interesting wildlife.
They went to various
all-night restaurants
that the kids loved.
So they actually had
a good time with that.
SCOTT MAXWELL: So you
studied all the instruments
on Curiosity in excruciating
detail for this book.
In that process, did you
come out with a favorite?
What's your favorite
instrument on Curiosity?
EMILY LAKDAWALLA: I
never have favorites.
SCOTT MAXWELL: She lied.
But go ahead.
EMILY LAKDAWALLA: I do have to
say that MAHLI is pretty cool.
MAHLI is a really
cool instrument.
So MAHLI stands for the
Mars Hand Lens Imager.
It's M-A-H-L-I.
It's the camera that's on
the end of the robotic arm.
And for reasons that I go into
exhaustive detail in the book,
it turns out to be the widest
angle color camera, also,
that the Rover has, so it
can take the broadest views.
And because it's on the
arm, the whole point of it
is to take images of targets
that they do their in-situ work
on with their instruments.
And so they'll use
MAHLI to take an image
from about a foot
away, and then they'll
zoom in and take one from about
five centimeters away, and then
another one from about one
or two centimeters away.
And that gets you a
nested set of images
at increasing resolution
that helps you see
what's going on in the rocks.
But because it's a
focusable camera,
it can also focus at infinity.
So you can take long distance
views and, of course,
you can turn it back
and look at the Rover.
And so it's the first Mars
Rover to demonstrate capability
of taking a self-portrait
on Mars, although notably,
Opportunity recently took
a self-portrait on Mars.
It, too, has an
arm-mounted camera.
Its camera is not
focusable, so the images
that it took of itself
were very blurry.
But it's still
unmistakably the Rover,
and it was really quite
a thrill to see that.
But yeah, it's become part of
standard operating procedure
for Curiosity to take a selfie
whenever it's at a drill site.
And so we have these
self-portraits of Curiosity
across the surface of Mars.
And you can see it getting
increasingly dusty.
The one that you're
seeing on the screen
up here is a special one.
The first self-portrait,
actually, that Curiosity
took was just of the
wheels on the surface.
And you want to do that so
that you can check and see
how the wheels are
contacting the surface,
check and see the condition of
the wheels after the landing.
And in order to
do that, they have
to have the arm
very low, obviously,
underneath the
undercarriage of the Rover.
Most of the selfies are
shot at an altitude that's
similar to the altitude
of the MastCam cameras
so that it's taking
a self-portrait.
But this one, they were
actually at a drill site
where the ground
sloped downward,
which made life, actually, quite
difficult for the drill team.
But because the ground
was sloping downward away
from the Rover, they were
able to turn the turret
and take a full selfie
from that low perspective.
So that's what gives you
this very low perspective
on the Rover.
And those
self-portraits are cool.
And some people on
the science team,
or on the engineering
team, were dubious.
But when the MAHLI principal
investigator, and a couple
of the workers on that
mission, simulated
what it could look
like and showed it
to the engineering team,
they were like, oh, my god,
we have to do this.
And so like with
everything, they
have to do it on Earth before
they can do it on Mars.
And so the first
selfie was actually
taken by the Earth copy,
the Earth twin of Curiosity,
inside its little garage
in the Mars Yard at JPL.
And you can see there's two
engineers in the background.
One of them is Vandi Verma.
She's peeking around
the corner as the camera
image is being taken.
It's pretty cool.
SCOTT MAXWELL: I'm
surprised that you said
the MAHLI was your favorite.
Because everybody, when you ask
what their favorite instrument
on Curiosity is, everybody
always says the laser,
because pew, pew, pew.
Come on.
EMILY LAKDAWALLA: It's a
Rover with a frickin' laser
beam on its head.
What's not to love about that?
SCOTT MAXWELL: Exactly.
EMILY LAKDAWALLA: And
actually, it is kind of fun.
There's very imaginative
artworks of Curiosity
zapping various things.
My favorite one,
actually, is one
that I first saw
in a ChemCam team.
ChemCam is the instrument
that has the laser.
They were doing a
team presentation
at a science meeting.
And they had a photo
of Curiosity shooting
a laser and a full on
Michael Bay explosion
happening at the
end of the laser.
So no, I like pictures.
What can I say?
Pictures tell us stories.
And I really like
the MAHLI pictures.
One thing ChemCam
has, though, is
it does have a camera on it to
take context images of where
they zap with their laser.
And later on in
the mission, they
trained the camera to be
able to focus at infinity
so that you can take
long distance photos.
And the camera has
this circular baffle
so it's the highest
resolution camera.
It can take the
most distant photos.
So it's just like
taking a spyglass
and seeing these long
distance features.
Ahoy, there's that
valley network
that we were going to
visit in the future.
And so I always kind of
feel like a ship's captain
every time I see those
ChemCam pictures.
SCOTT MAXWELL: Just
so it's clear--
I didn't mean to disagree
with you about the MAHLI
because I think it's
a very strong choice.
MAHLI also has a flashlight
on it, which is--
Kim, my wife, who
works on Curiosity--
her favorite is the flashlight
attached to the MAHLI.
EMILY LAKDAWALLA: There's
actually two flashlights.
And the reason for that
is because, if you're
a geologist working in the
field with your rock hammer,
you smash off a piece of fresh
rock to look at the crystals
inside and try to identify
what minerals are present.
You'll do this with
the rock sample
to try to catch
glints from the sun
to see if there's
reflective surfaces
and what the angles
are to each other.
Well, Curiosity can't do that.
But what it can do is take its
two little flashlights on MAHLI
and go blink, blink,
blink, blink, blink,
blink to do lights coming
from two different directions.
And so that's what it does to
try to catch crystal glints.
I don't know that it's
ever worked that way.
But they do use the flashlights
at night because that way,
they have a light source of
known illumination properties.
And so all the night
images that they've
taken of all of
their drill sites,
they can compare the
color to each other
because they're all
taken under exactly
the same illumination
conditions.
SCOTT MAXWELL: So in addition
to the laser on the Rover,
I actually learned from your
book--this is not a thing that
I realized before
reading your book--
but I learned from
your book that DAN,
the Dynamic Albedo of Neutrons
experiment, has an ion cannon.
So we've got a laser
and an ion cannon,
and now all we need is a
Rover with a light saber,
and we've got the trifecta.
EMILY LAKDAWALLA:
That's right, yeah.
SCOTT MAXWELL: Another
really cool thing
I learned about the
science instruments
from reading the book
was about the rad, which
has the scintillating
plastic detector.
I love that name.
I've decided that scintillating
plastic detector is
the name of my muse cover band.
EMILY LAKDAWALLA: Yeah.
There's all kinds of fun terms.
And they tend to squeeze all
of these terms into acronyms.
And so you talk about
SAMs, TLS, and QMS
and doing GCMS on
all of the samples.
And I think it's
actually a lot more fun
to say gas chromatograph
mass spectrometer.
It sounds like Star Trekese.
Let's fire things up in our
oven and send them through--
what is it, the manifolds?
There are many
manifolds inside SAM,
and you send it with your helium
carrier gas through manifold A
and send it off to the
tunable laser spectrometer.
And it's just fun.
There's a lot of fun terms.
SCOTT MAXWELL: So again, having
studied all the instruments
in this exhaustive detail,
as you say, which of them
do you think was the most
complicated instrument
of all of them on the Rover?
EMILY LAKDAWALLA: That
one's easy to answer.
But the first thing
I want to answer
is when he says
exhaustive detail,
exhaustive is the
most common adjective
used to describe my book.
And I'm just glad that
it's not exhausting.
So yeah.
SCOTT MAXWELL: It's
fascinating, but exhaustive.
EMILY LAKDAWALLA: Right.
So definitely, without question,
the most complicated instrument
is the SAM instrument.
So SAM means Sample
Analysis at Mars.
It's one of two
laboratory instruments.
And it's interesting
that the two laboratory
instruments, one of them
is really very simple
and that's CheMin.
That's an instrument
that has a laser that it
shines through a little
sample of powder.
And it shakes the powder
so that those crystals all
toss around in various
different orientations.
And the crystals
scatter the light,
and you get a diffraction plot.
It's the same kind of technology
that Rosalind Franklin
used to figure out
the structure of DNA.
You're doing x-ray
crystallography, basically.
And that's all it is.
You take a picture
of the diffraction,
and then you download that
picture, and you can say,
ah, these minerals are present.
And that's it.
And that's one of the two
laboratory instruments.
But then there's SAM.
And SAM is ridiculous.
I cannot believe they actually
built this instrument and put
it on a Rover on Mars.
It has a carousel of more
than 70 little quartz cups.
It can rotate this carousel
under two different inlets
to receive samples.
Then it rotates the carousel
and lifts a cup into an oven.
In the oven, it can heat
things up to 500 degrees.
It can heat it in steps.
It can heat it with a ramp.
It can heat it for a little
bit, then hold it or not.
It can heat it all the way.
It can heat it partway.
It can take it down and
bring it back up again.
And then there is a
little helium tank
that takes all of the gases
that come off of the oven
and sends them into one of
numerous possible different
instruments.
But before that, it sends them
into these little chambers
called manifolds.
A manifold is a
place where you have
lots of things intersecting.
And by opening and closing one
of dozens of different valves,
they can send the material
on to different getters
and scrubbers, which take
certain stuff out of the gases.
They can turn on a getter
for a little while,
and then heat the getter
to release the stuff again.
And then they send that into one
of three different instruments.
So there's all these valves.
There's all these different
ways, all these knobs to turn.
They actually
developed, basically,
a programming language that the
SAM team can use to send things
through the SAM instrument.
One of the wackiest
things, I think,
is that the PI on
the SAM instrument
was very proud of the fact
that he programs it in Basic.
I was like, I know very little
about programming languages,
but I know enough to
know that that's not
something to be proud of.
SCOTT MAXWELL: It's
not widely used
at Google, that's for sure.
EMILY LAKDAWALLA: I'm sure.
So anyway, it's
incredibly complicated.
And to most people, it's just
a box that the SAM team asks
for knobs to be turned,
and they turn the knobs,
and data comes out.
And then, even once
you have the data,
you still don't have answers
because the kinds of things
that they're trying
to figure out
are so complex that the only way
to be sure that you've figured
it out right is to create a
sample of known composition
and put it through a
duplicate of the instrument
in a lab on Earth under
Martian conditions.
So that's temperature
and vacuum.
So SAM results-- there's
actually going to be a press
conference tomorrow concerning
a science paper that--
one of the main people
on the press panel
is Paul Mahaffey, who is
the principal investigator
on this instrument.
And so I'm sure that
the paper concerns
data that was taken at least six
months ago, probably years ago,
because that's just
how long it takes
to understand the results
from this instrument.
Fortunately, there
are other instruments
that produce much more
rapid results, and make
things a little more interesting
for those of us following along
in the mission.
SCOTT MAXWELL: So the SAM
instrument has another talent.
If there were a
talent show on Mars,
Curiosity's entry
would be singing.
EMILY LAKDAWALLA: That's right.
SAM famously sang
"Happy Birthday"
to itself using
its SAM instrument.
I actually don't know
the details of what
was vibrating or making noise.
Was it an FPGA or something?
SCOTT MAXWELL: I don't
know the details.
My wife is the instrument
engineer for the SAM
instrument, and so
she could probably
tell us about that
in exhausting detail.
EMILY LAKDAWALLA: So
anyway, but this story
does surface once a year.
But I am here to tell you it
does not sing "Happy Birthday"
to itself every year.
It did that once on Mars.
It was a cute little
stunt, and that's it.
SCOTT MAXWELL: So we've been
talking for about 40 minutes.
Let's throw it out for
audience questions, as well.
And while we're getting--
oh, have you seen
our microphone?
This is really cool.
The microphone's in a
little box, a soft box,
and they can just throw
the box around the room.
But while we're waiting
for that, let me ask you.
You were saying the SAM
instrument is the most
complicated instrument.
Was it also the
hardest to explain?
EMILY LAKDAWALLA: It was
absolutely, by far, the hardest
to explain.
You'll find about 50 pages
of this book on the SAM
instrument.
And I wore Paul Mahaffey out
asking him questions about--
because when I first
started writing this,
I envisioned, you heat
stuff up, you get a gas,
and it goes through the
machine and comes out.
But that's not how
it works at all.
You heat it up, you get a
gas, it goes into one place,
then you open a valve and
it goes into this place.
Then you might be turning on
something that pumps slightly,
but not too much.
And you get a gradient going.
It's so incredibly complicated
that the main comment
that I get from people on the
mission who are not on the SAM
team is, thank god
somebody finally
explained this to me because
I had no idea how it worked.
AUDIENCE: So I
was wondering, how
does the delay
between Earth and Mars
affect the teams that
operate the Rover?
Is it a lot easier to do work
when Earth and Mars are close
together?
EMILY LAKDAWALLA:
So no, actually.
That's a good question.
So Mars and Earth have a
widely differing distance
to each other, which affects
the communications lag.
But the fact of the matter
is that because the lag is
many minutes, regardless
of the relative distances,
there's no real-time commanding.
So you are always doing a
full sol worth of sequencing
at a minimum.
The Rover receives its commands
at 10:00 AM every morning,
Mars time.
And so the reason
that they do that
is because Earth is always
up in Mars's sky at 10:00
AM local time.
Earth is closer to
the sun than Mars is,
so it's always somewhere
relatively close to the sun.
And so if you're doing your
commanding at 10:00 AM,
Earth will always be up in the
sky, although sometimes it can
be a little low on the horizon.
And so the Rover executes its
one sol's worth of commands.
And then in the
afternoon, there are
overflights by two Mars
orbiters, Mars Odyssey and Mars
Reconnaissance Orbiter.
And it sends its data
through a UHF connection
up to the orbiter,
which receives the data
and then relays it onto Earth.
And there's also overnight
passes by the orbiters.
And so you wind up having to
command at minimum one sol
increments.
And so it really
doesn't matter how close
Mars is, except that you can
get much higher bandwidth
in your transmissions
between Mars and Earth
when Mars is closer.
So you do get more data
returned from the orbiter
because it can
communicate faster.
You can use a higher data
rate when they're close.
And so you'll see these
seasonal spikes in data rate
that are not actually seasonal.
They happen when Mars is nearer
opposition, when Earth and Mars
are close to each other.
And then, on the opposite side,
when Mars gets into conjunction
with the sun, you
actually have three weeks
where you're not allowed to
talk to the Rover at all.
Because if there
were a problem, you
couldn't be sure
that your message
would get through ungarbled
to be able to save the Rover.
So all the spacecraft
kind of hunker down
and go into a fairly
low activity mode
during conjunction.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
Are there pieces of
the Rover that it
can separate from itself?
Like, in the selfie
picture, I don't
see how there's
something attached to it
that would take the selfie.
EMILY LAKDAWALLA: Right.
So the question of
who took the picture
and how the selfie
works is one that
pops up every single
time I post a selfie.
The issue is that, although
the field of view of the MAHLI
camera is fairly wide, it's
not anywhere near as wide
as the kind of camera you
have on your cell phone.
It's actually very narrow.
So in order to take a
selfie, the Rover actually
takes about 70
pictures of itself
in kind of a matrix sort of way.
And it repositions the arm
to keep the arm out of view.
It would never be able to
photograph its whole arm
regardless.
And so you wind up
mosaicing an image together
like this out of multiple
different images.
And they just do it in a way so
that the arm is not constantly
poking into view from all
these different directions.
Because when you
do take the selfie,
you will see the arm
in multiple images.
And so you have to come up with
a way of neatly cutting it off.
You actually see more of
the arm in this picture
than you see in most
of the self-portraits.
Usually they chop it
off at the shoulder.
Because otherwise,
it would be crossing
the front of the Rover.
But because of all
those multiple pictures,
you wind up being able
to get the arm out of it.
And there's no
real sensible way.
One of the more disconcerting
images that I've seen
was a self-portrait taken
by the MastCam, which
is the only way that
Opportunity and Spirit can
take self-portraits.
You can get a mosaic of
the deck of the Rover
by shooting multiple
images with the MastCam.
And in those images,
of course, the mast
is missing because it can't
photograph the MastCam.
It can't photograph
its own mast.
And so you get a
great view of the arm,
but the Rover's headless, and
it's really kind of disturbing.
AUDIENCE: Wasn't
this the one that had
the really difficult landing?
Like, it was really complicated,
and they were really
worried about it?
SCOTT MAXWELL: She goes into
a lot of detail about that
in the book, by the way.
It's really fascinating.
EMILY LAKDAWALLA: Yeah.
So it's kind of funny.
It was a really
complicated landing.
It's a Rube Goldbergian landing.
The problem with
landing on Mars is
that it has enough
atmosphere to burn you up,
but not enough atmosphere
to slow you down.
So it's easier to
land on the moon.
It's easier to land on Earth.
On the moon, no atmosphere.
You just streak in, blast
with retrorockets, boom,
you're on the
surface, no problem.
On Earth, parachute
and heat shield
slows you down
enough where you just
kind of coast into a landing.
That's what the
space shuttles did.
That's what all the
Apollo capsules did.
On Mars you have to combine
all of those things.
So you have a heat
shield that takes you
from interplanetary
travel speeds down
to supersonic speeds.
Then you have a
parachute that takes you
from supersonic to subsonic.
Then you have
rockets that slow you
down from subsonic to still.
And then you have to touch down.
And different missions
have accomplished
this in different ways.
Most Mars missions are landers.
And so what the landers
typically do is they
get down to--
SCOTT MAXWELL: Landers
as opposed to Rovers.
EMILY LAKDAWALLA: As
opposed to Rovers.
Yeah, sorry.
So they get pretty
close to the surface.
And then, usually, they
cut off their rockets
right above the
surface because you
don't want to be blasting the
surface with a lot of rocket
exhaust.
And so they'll have
crushable legs.
That's what Phoenix
and Insight have.
They have legs that can take
up that last bit of drop.
Or you'll have what Spirit
and Opportunity had,
which are the
airbags surrounding,
and it actually bounced to a
halt, which I think is nutty.
I mean, take a ridiculously
expensive machine
and whack it on the
surface multiple times.
That's what Spirit and
Opportunity and Pathfinder did.
And so Curiosity's approach--
Curiosity was already too big to
have any extra lander hardware.
And so it said it had a
rocket-assisted backpack
that it lowered the
Rover on a rope,
and then gently let the
Rover touch the surface.
And there's slack on the cables.
And once the machine
detected that there's
slack on the cables,
it cuts the cables
and flies the jet pack away.
You can just imagine, it's just
like in a Wiley Coyote cartoon.
Whew, clunk.
and then there's a big
explosion and a boom and stuff.
SCOTT MAXWELL: Which
we got a picture of.
EMILY LAKDAWALLA: Which we
actually got a picture of.
SCOTT MAXWELL: It was amazing.
EMILY LAKDAWALLA: The
first Curiosity image
from the surface of Mars was
taken by its rear hazcam.
And you see this plume
of dust on the horizon.
And they later figured
out that that was probably
the plume from the
explosion of the jet pack
when it crashed on the surface,
which I think is just great.
So it's an incredibly
complicated landing.
But as I explain
in the book, it's
actually not really
out of family
from what had been done before.
Hanging the Rover on
a rope was actually
exactly what they did with
Spirit and Opportunity.
That airbag thingy was hanging
on a rope off of the retro
rockets.
And so the landing
looked ridiculous.
But it was very well-modeled.
And after they had the
two-year launch delay,
I have never seen engineers
as confident as I saw.
I mean, engineers, as a rule,
are not confident people.
They're like, well, it might
work if all the conditions
are right, bla bla bla.
They don't want to tell
you it's absolutely
going to work because, as they
say in the rocket business,
there's 1,000 ways for a
launch to go wrong, only one
way for it to go right.
But they had the last two years
to really prepare and throw
all kinds of situations at it.
You know, dust storms
and bad navigation
and failure of one of the
rockets and all kinds of stuff.
And the machine, in
their simulations,
performed with flying colors.
And in the final event, it was
just straight down the middle.
Everything was nominal,
nominal, nominal,
except for one little detail
that maybe I'll let you
guys read the book for.
SCOTT MAXWELL: So
software people--
while the mic is going
to the next person--
software people
like us understand
the concept of Easter eggs.
Little hidden things in,
maybe, your web browser.
You hit Control-Alt-Shift-S and
it pops up a flight simulator
or something like that.
EMILY LAKDAWALLA: Right.
SCOTT MAXWELL: And Curiosity
has one of those Easter eggs,
as well, in the wheels.
Before they had
not-on-purpose holes in them,
they had on-purpose
holes in them.
EMILY LAKDAWALLA: That's right.
So if you look at the
wheels of the Rover,
you can see that there are
deliberately a whole bunch
of holes punched in them.
This is kind of a callback
to Spirit and Opportunity.
They were connected
to their lander
with these bolts that were fired
and separated after landing.
And so there are holes on
Spirit and Opportunity's wheels
that are there
just as an artifact
of the method by which they
were attached to the lander.
But they turned out to be really
useful for the science team
because you can see the little
mark that the holes left
in the wheel tracks to
actually measure distances.
You can also use it to see how
much the Rover wheels slipped
during driving.
So you can kind of measure
distances in one way
and then in a different way, and
see how long or short it was.
And the Rover
actually got to where
it was using this for odometry.
It could actually use
its own wheel tracks
to help understand how
far it had traveled.
So they wanted to include
some kind of odometry marking
on the wheels on
Curiosity to make sure
that it would be easy to tell
how many wheel turns there
had been in the Rover tracks.
And so the first thing they
did was that they actually
machined the letters JPL into
the wheels, into the treads.
And so there's a picture in my
book of an early set of wheels
that has JPL on it, so it
left tracks, JPL, JPL, JPL,
as it was going.
And NASA was like, you
guys can't do that.
So they came up
with another plan,
which was to put the letters
JPL in the wheels in Morse code.
So that's what you see.
There's three rows
there, and they
have narrower and
wider gaps, and that's
the letters JPL in Morse code.
AUDIENCE: So this isn't
actually a Curiosity question,
because there's something
else you mentioned
earlier that's been bugging me.
You said the Russians landed
a mostly mechanical lander
on Venus, and the
electronics wouldn't stand up
to the surface temperatures.
How did they communicate
the information
off the planet to us?
EMILY LAKDAWALLA:
Well, I don't actually
know enough about how
those missions worked.
They did have a pressure vessel,
a temperature-safe vessel,
on the inside that had
the limited electronics
that there were.
And they did do radio
communications direct to Earth.
They didn't have
orbiters, so they
were doing it direct to Earth.
But then, Venus is actually
relatively close to Earth,
so you don't have to
have very powerful radio
to get that data back.
I'm afraid I'm not an
electronics person myself,
so I don't really know the
answer to that question.
SCOTT MAXWELL: We're starting
to run a little low on time.
And it kills me
that we're not going
to get to all the questions
I want to ask you.
Maybe we should take one
more audience question,
and I'll ask you a wrap-up here.
EMILY LAKDAWALLA: OK.
AUDIENCE: So my question
is, what happens
if something mechanical fails?
Is there any self-repair
kind of capability?
EMILY LAKDAWALLA: There is not.
But there's a lot of
redundancy-- a lot
of redundant capability.
So there's a lot of
planning done to figure out
how the Rover can still
accomplish its mission even
if this, that, or
another component fails.
So the computer systems
are fully redundant.
There's an A side and a B
side, and various components
are cross-strapped
to each other.
So when a computer fails, as
actually happened 200 days
into the mission, they
can swap to the backup
and operate on the backup while
they repair the prime computer.
And so they've done that with
the main computer already.
It actually took
them a long time
to bring the backup back
online, which was kind of scary.
There have been mechanical
problems like problems
with the wheels.
And so you get through
that through robustness.
Basically, any one of
the wheels, the motors
are powerful enough to raise
the entire Rover's weight
vertically.
So if you attached a rope
to it, you could wind a rope
on one of the
wheels, and the motor
is strong enough to be able
to lift the whole Rover.
This actually became important
for Spirit and Opportunity
because both of them have
had different kinds of wheel
failures.
And so Spirit, in particular,
was dragging one of its wheels
for a long time.
But the Rover was still
able to drive that way.
SCOTT MAXWELL: And
it's a good thing
because we made some science
discoveries because of that.
EMILY LAKDAWALLA: Yeah.
And so the biggest
problem that Curiosity
has been dealing with lately
is a major mechanical failure
in the drill.
So the drill used to operate
with a pair of prongs
that it pressed against a rock.
And then there was
a feed mechanism
that pushed the
drill into the rock
while everything
else stayed still.
And the feed mechanism
failed almost completely.
It was very sticky.
They couldn't get it to
move backward and forward,
which is critical for drilling.
And so over the period
of more than a year now,
they've managed to get the bulky
feed to extend all the way.
So now the feed is
permanently extended.
And they-- just a couple of
weeks ago-- for the first time,
managed to do what they call
feed-extended drilling, where
instead of using the
feed mechanism, which
no longer works, they're
now using arm motors.
So it's like taking
a drill and trying
to drill into a wall like this.
You can imagine, it's
hard, but Curiosity's arm
is pretty strong.
And so they just kind
of lean on the arm
and they push the drill into
the rock, and it worked.
So it's taken them a
long time to fix it.
But these engineers are really
ingenious at solving problems.
And so a lot of what you
do on an extended mission,
and extended extended
mission, which
is what Curiosity is
on now, is figure out
how to make the most of
an aging machine that does
have problems but can still
do great science where it is.
And so all these people
have a lot of experience
in making old,
groany machines work.
I mean, I'd like to write
a book about Galileo,
about all the things
they had to keep
that thing going after
radiation fried it
at Jupiter multiple times.
And so Curiosity's still
got a lot of life in it.
They'll have problems.
They wish the problems weren't
there, but they're like,
OK, this is our new reality,
and we'll keep going.
That's how it works.
SCOTT MAXWELL: So
it's killing me
that I've got, like,
20 more questions here
and we've got three minutes.
So that's not enough
time, I'm thinking.
But maybe we can
end on this note,
by asking you what do you
hope readers will take away
from this gorgeous,
terrific book
that I could not more
highly recommend?
EMILY LAKDAWALLA: Oh, gosh.
I guess I hope that people will
take away the fact that they
can understand this is a
very complicated machine,
but what it's doing, why
it's there, and how it works
are not inaccessible
to everyone.
And that's one of the great
things about space exploration,
I think, is that it's easy to
explain why we're doing it,
the fundamental questions
we're trying to answer.
Was there ever life on Mars,
are we alone in the universe?
That kind of stuff.
And it's fairly
easy to understand
how we're going about
solving those problems.
We're sending a robot with a
drill that's sampling rocks,
and we put them into a lab.
And all of these things you
can communicate with children.
You can communicate with
science-interested adults,
as well.
And it's just very accessible,
and everybody can kind of
participate in the
adventure by following along
with what they're doing.
They share their raw
images straight from Mars
directly on the internet
that, every day,
you can tune in at JPL and
see what they've been doing.
I highly recommend
midnightplanets.com.
It's an enthusiast-built
website that
aggregates all of the images
from the different rovers
and puts them up in ways
that are easy to see.
And it's just a fun adventure,
and we're all part of it,
basically.
SCOTT MAXWELL: Emily, I'm so
sad that we're out of time.
But I enthusiastically
recommend this book.
The book is "The Design and
Engineering of Curiosity:
How the Mars Rover
Performs Its Job."
All the stuff you've
heard us talk about today,
and a whole lot more
stuff, is in there.
It's really terrific.
I highly recommend it.
EMILY LAKDAWALLA: It's also on
my blog at planetary.org/blog.
You'll find I write updates
about every two or three months
on what Curiosity is doing.
I'll probably have a new one
out in a couple of weeks.
SCOTT MAXWELL: I wish we
had another hour to talk,
but maybe you'll be
able to come back
and we'll be able to do it then.
In the meantime, please join
me in thanking our guest today,
Emily Lakdawalla.
[APPLAUSE]